you might expect google maps to know
where you are and facebook to know who
you're in touch with but some privacy
offenders are a little less obvious
Angry Birds is what the NSA calls a
leaky app which they can easily exploit
for personal data and to track your
movements messaging apps like snapchat
and kicks for very badly when it comes
to keeping your message is safe
linkedin's terms of service give it
permission to claim anything you share
on the professional networking service
and change it share it or profit from it
so make sure you read through an app's
privacy policy or else you'll be giving
away more than just your selfies